and then I would say to Drake 21 her
loss for sure really already you're
gonna put her loss up there that fast
yeah you're gonna let it marinate a
little bit no I don't need to I just
heard I heard it and I just knew it was
the best meme action of the year that
too like so many different reasons my
son who's [__] eight years old
he's not listening to the album once
sings that part yeah because he'd be on
Tick Tock and [__] yeah YouTube and I'm
like bro how do you know this that's
good he's like Drake's zesty Dad
hey yo I'm like what that's crazy that's
not that is that that video game clip
where someone created Dragon yeah what's
the average of Drake's walking yeah that
[__] is hilarious with album's classic
though I love it no it's a great album
and I think um Drake went in man that's
been about you record is so hard oh my
God they both snapped I I prefer this
over I think this is my favorite Drake
project since uh if you're reading this
probably since if you're reading this
it's too late